Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhodassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhodassa
Homage to the Buddha, the blessed, noble and fully self-enlightened one Homage to the Buddha, the blessed, noble and fully self-enlightened one
Quindi questa mattina ho pensato di rivisitare per quelli di voi che sono old hands nel buddismo e di introdurre quelli che sono nuovi ai concetti di originazione dipendente.
quindi questa sera volevo ripassare per coloro di voi che già hanno un po' di esperienza nella pratica e introdurre per chi invece non ce li ha per i nuovi i concetti dell'originazione dipendente la frase la ruota dell'originazione dipendente o interdipendente è stata fatta o coinata dai tibetani
Quindi questo termine, questa espressione, la ruota dell'originazione dipendente o dell'originazione interdipendente o della produzione, giusto Piero?
Sì, condizionata.
Condizionata, è stata coniata dal buddismo tibetano.
Sono sicuro che la maggior parte di voi abbiano visto la figura della ruota dell'originazione interdipendente, no?
In Theravada si chiama originazione dipendente.
Prima di cominciare vorrei di nuovo menzionare
come vi ricordate ieri è diventato pienamente illuminato sulla via del letto lui era un cugino del Buddha e quando ha chiesto al Buddha se potesse essere il suo attendente personale ha fatto una condizione
quindi quando lui ha chiesto al Buddha di diventare il suo attendente personale ha posto una condizione quindi la condizione era che lui dovesse essere presente a tutti i discorsi del Buddha e se invece fosse stato assente il Buddha doveva rispondere
Quindi pare che avesse questa memoria incredibile.
Quindi aveva questo intelletto molto forte, molto vivace e ovviamente una buona mente.
Dopo un paio di anni, forse 10-15 anni, lui disse al Buddha, penso che ora capisco questa dottrina dell'originazione dipendente.
E il Buddha disse, oh no Ananda, questa lezione è molto sottile, va molto profondo.
Questo era un avvertimento per una persona molto intelligente come Ananda, quindi anche voi dovete prendere questo avvertimento, avere questa attenzione.
Quando state ascoltando me.
Quindi avete notato quando recitiamo questo al mattino che comincia dalla ignoranza e va via via salendo attraversando tutti i vari gradi della condizione triste dell'uomo.
Quindi quando comincia questo processo di purificazione e di risveglio non torniamo indietro per quella lista.
Iniziamo di nuovo dal basso, ma diciamo che perché non c'è questo, non c'è quello.
E la posizione basica di tutti gli esseri sentienti, ma parliamo specificamente degli esseri umani, è che partiamo da una posizione di non conoscere.
A volte, in inglese comunque, usano il termine ignoranza.
Quindi spesso, qualche volta, insomma, in inglese si usa la parola ignoranza.
Però per me questo ha un significato, un connotato un po' peggiorativo, è come dire tu sei ignorante perché sei stupido.
Ma non è così, è semplicemente un non conoscere, un non sapere.
E quindi è proprio questo non conoscere che soggiace, che sta sotto tutta la nostra vita.
Il nostro problema è che noi pensiamo di conoscere ed è questa la nostra illusione principale.
Per esempio, noi crediamo di essere esseri umani.
Questo è un grande errore.
Quindi, iniziamo con questa idea che non sappiamo, poi entriamo in questa vita e in ogni momento da quella posizione di non sapere.
E quindi noi da questa posizione del non conoscere noi entriamo in tutti gli aspetti della nostra vita, della vita.
Quindi considerate il feto nell'utero.
Cosa conosce?
quindi probabilmente da quella posizione di non conoscere nulla comincia ad attivare i sensi quindi a sentire la voce della madre o il battito del cuore, il calore e poi ovviamente quando è nato i cinque sensi sono più sviluppati e più informazione entra
Quindi quando nasce i cinque sensi sono più sviluppati e cominciano ad arrivare a maggiori informazioni.
Quindi non ha nessun modo per comprendere questi stimoli.
Quindi parte dal non conoscere e poi improvvisamente c'è la luce, c'è il sentire, c'è il toccare.
E attraverso tutte queste cose comincia a creare il mondo.
Comincia poi a crescere, a conoscere a un livello più profondo la cultura, il linguaggio
e le credenze di quella cultura è un altro modo per giudicare o criticare o farsi un'opinione che non sia quella che gli viene data
e quindi questo poveretto insomma riceve non solo tutte le cose buone da quella cultura ma anche tutte le cose cattive e attraverso la sua vita dovremmo dire attraverso la sua vita anche tutte le illusioni in quella cultura sì e attraverso la sua vita inizia a sviluppare quello che chiamiamo il suo carattere e la sua personalità
E per tutta la sua vita comincia a sviluppare quello che noi chiamiamo il suo carattere, la sua personalità.
Ora, nella psicologia buddhista, e questo è perché sto cercando di stressare per voi, di raggiungere tutte le vostre intenzioni, tutta la psicologia della creazione di questo me, o mia, inizia con un'intenzione.
dunque nella psicologia buddista ed è per questo che io metto proprio l'accento sull'intenzione secondo la psicologia buddista appunto tutto nasce proprio cioè il me, il io questo concetto di me e di io nasce proprio dalla mettere questa intenzione intenzione quindi quando abbiamo un'intenzione quindi mettiamo energia nell'intenzione impariamo
quindi quando abbiamo un'intenzione noi mettiamo energia in quella intenzione noi gli diamo forza attraverso un atto di volontà prendete per esempio la meditazione camminata quindi potete stare lì in piedi e sentire, conoscere l'intenzione di camminare
Potete continuare a pensare, intenzione di camminare, intenzione di camminare, intenzione di camminare, ma nulla si muove.
Quindi cosa è che prende qualcosa dal potenziale in un attuale?
Questo è ciò a cui si riferiva Buddha quando parlava di volontà.
Quando mettete la volontà in un'intenzione diventa un'azione.
E se continuate a ripetere l'azione diventa un abito.
E se continuate a ripetere questa azione diventa un'abitudine.
E quando avete un sacco di abitudini questo è quello che noi chiamiamo una personalità.
quindi tutto questo condizionamento nasce da quel punto di partenza del non conoscere quindi i primi due passaggi diciamo di questa ruota dell'originazione indipendente sono il non conoscere e poi l'abitudine
Ci sono due tipi di insegnamento a riguardo di questa originazione dipendente.
Allora, l'insegnamento tradizionale dice che questa originazione indipendente si allunga, diciamo, alla durata di tre vite.
Quindi entriamo in questa forma di vita con questa ignoranza, con questo non sapere e con le condizioni della vita precedente.
Quindi noi entriamo in questa vita con questa condizione di non conoscenza e dei condizionamenti della vita precedente.
Poi come vedete alla fine della ruota, dell'originazione dipendente, c'è il crescere, il diventare vecchi e il morire.
E quella è la vita futura.
Ma...
Per noi, come meditatori, è molto più importante vedere questo accadere nel momento presente.
Quindi, dal momento in cui siamo nati, c'è questo non conoscere.
Quindi al momento in cui nasciamo c'è questo sottostante stato di non conoscenza.
A cosa si riferisce questo non conoscere?
Si riferisce al non conoscere le tre caratteristiche.
Non vediamo, non vediamo realmente che le cose sono impermanenti.
Non riusciamo a vedere che non potremmo mai ottenere pace e felicità attraverso il mondo sensuale, sensoriale.
E non riusciamo a vedere che questa idea di io, mio o della personalità umana è solo un concetto.
Per questo ho detto all'inizio che è un grande errore considerare noi stessi degli esseri umani.
Ovviamente non lo dico in un senso convenzionale, in un senso convenzionale siamo ovviamente tutti degli esseri umani, ma per quanto riguarda la realtà ultima non la siamo.
semplicemente perché moriamo.
Con questi due stati sottostanti, il non sapere e le condizioni, entriamo in questo organismo psicofisico.
quindi da questi due stati sottostanti del non conoscere e delle condizioni noi entriamo in questo corpo psicofisico adesso dice anche i termini in pali così chi lo conosce sa a cosa si sta riferendo quindi l'ignoranza è Awija e le condizioni le chiamiamo Sankara
e Sankara sono le condizioni questo organismo psicofisico è Nama Rupa il Rupa si riferisce a questo corpo e Nama si riferisce a ciò che normalmente chiamiamo la nostra vita pensativa, emotiva, perceptuale, tutto il resto
E quindi per nama si intende tutto il resto, cioè il nostro mondo percettivo, concettuale.
Sì, quindi ci sono, come voi forse sapete, cinque aggregati, cinque khanda.
Ed è così che il Buddha vedeva l'essere umano.
Il primo è Rupa, il corpo.
Poi ci sono le percezioni.
Il modo in cui noi percepiamo il colore, la forma, le cose del genere.
feelings but yes sensazioni then there are all these sankara so these sankara is what we would call our emotional thought life and finally the act of cognition
e infine l'atto della cognizione quindi il modo in cui la mente e il cervello può tenere fermo qualcosa per noi per esempio se avete visto questi diagrammi di come le persone guardano una pittura
vedrete che l'occhio non vede nemmeno la immagine, l'occhio prende solo piccoli pezzi qui e lì, e questo è messo insieme nel complesso del cervello-mind come una immagine.
E quel conoscere, quel modo di conoscere è l'atto di cognizione.
si può anche dire coscienza ma coscienza è una parola molto grande molto vasta il primo atto del conoscere questo non significa non indica il secondo atto che è sapere di sapere
Questo sapere di sapere o sapere di conoscere è il sati che noi stiamo sviluppando.
quindi questo Nama Rupa questo complesso mente-corpo ha sei modi per interagire col mondo per conoscere il mondo quindi non vi sorprenderete di sapere che sono i nostri cinque sensi più la mente stessa
Quindi noterete che questi cinque sensi non possono essere confusi uno con l'altro.
Il Buddha usa la parola ayatana, che significa una sfera di esperienza.
che sta a significare una sfera di esperienza quindi le orecchie possono solo sentire, non possono vedere quindi ogni senso ha un suo modo per contattare e fare esperienza del mondo e la mente naturalmente ha il suo modo
Quindi attraverso questi sei sensi che noi contattiamo il mondo.
Quindi questo contatto è il principale
e per un momento di contatto c'è bisogno del senso organico, dell'oggetto e di questo atto di cognizione
Quindi perché ci sia questo contatto ci vuole l'oggetto, l'organo di senso e questo atto cognitivo.
Forse avete avuto l'esperienza di chiedervi da dove arrivava un libido.
Perché la vostra mente era catturata in qualcos'altro, voi non vi siete accorti del vostro gomito che andava a sbattere contro qualcosa.
Quindi qui abbiamo i primi due...
Ora, da tutti questi contatti diversi, iniziamo a dividere il mondo in qualcosa di piacerevole, di non piacerevole e di neutrale.
Quindi attraverso questi contatti noi cominciamo a dividere il mondo in cose piacevoli, sgradevoli e neutre.
E questo lo chiamiamo vedana.
Quindi le sensazioni di contatto e questo vedana sono la stessa cosa tranne che nel vedana c'è ancora questo aspetto del distinguerli impiacevoli, spiacevoli e neutri.
Tutto questo processo è automatico.
Non puoi fermarlo.
Non lo potete interrompere.
Quindi immediatamente, appena vedete qualcosa, ci sarà il contatto e voi saprete se vi piace, non vi piace o è neutro.
E ciò che stiamo facendo nella nostra meditazione è centrare sul Vedana.
Stiamo centrando sul Vedana
in modo da vedere cosa succede dopo.
E quello che succede dopo è TANHA.
Quindi questo TANHA è il desiderio di divertirsi, di indulgere, o il desiderio di spingere fuori, o il desiderio di uscire fuori.
ricorda che questa parola tanha è specifica a questo processo di desiderio che viene da questa ignoranza
Quindi sappiate che questo tanna è proprio relativo al processo del desiderare che è legato con questa ignoranza.
C'è un'altra parola in Pali che è chanda che anch'essa si riferisce al desiderio ma è un desiderio sano, salutare.
che non è provocato dall'ignoranza.
Quindi ricordate dopo il suo risveglio nel Buddha è nato questo desiderio di predicare agli altri il Dhamma, insegnare il Dhamma.
Per inciso, voi sentirete o leggerete che alcuni dicono che Buddha aveva la scelta di non insegnare.
E questo perché quando si guardò intorno e vede a cui, o pensò a chi doveva ricevere questi insegnamenti, capì che non c'era nessuno che fosse pronto per riceverli.
E' solo perché il grande Dio, la Divinità, Sahampati, venne e gli disse, no, per favore, insegna il Dhamma.
Alcune persone hanno solo un po' di polvere negli occhi.
Questo Brahma Sahampati rappresenta naturalmente la saggezza del Buddha.
E sebbene ci fosse questo dubbio riguardo al fatto che le persone fossero pronte a ricevere gli insegnamenti, secondo il Venerabile non c'era alcun dubbio nella sua mente rispetto al fatto che andassero insegnate e che il Dhamma andasse trasmesso.
E il motivo per cui lo dico è per l'ottupice sentiero.
Perché non puoi avere la visita senza la virtù.
perché non puoi avere saggezza senza la virtù quindi quello era un piccolo inciso quindi qui adesso abbiamo questo problema di tanha quindi questo è il primo movimento della mente che si avvicina all'oggetto per farne qualcosa
Vuole crearsi questo paradiso interiore, indulgendo il cibo.
Oppure vuole eliminare il vicino di casa per tutto il casino che sta facendo.
E spesso non siamo neanche consapevoli di queste sensazioni neutrali.
In effetti, un esercizio di guardare il respiro ci mette in contatto con le sensazioni neutrali, a volte per la prima volta nella nostra vita.
E quindi effettivamente questo esercizio dell'entrare in contatto con il nostro respiro ci fa avere esperienza, entrare in contatto con questi stati neutrali per la prima volta.
E il passo successivo, che è quello automatico, è del punto in cui noi perdiamo il controllo.
E questo è chiamato Uppadana.
Questo è chiamato Uppadana.
Che significa afferrare.
Ed è qui che entra Dio.
Subito dopo c'è il potenziamento della volontà e l'azione.
Questa azione fa parte di quel condizionamento interno alla persona.
E quindi questa persona è come se si ricreasse.
E questo è il divenire.
Quindi i collegamenti, prima di tutto c'è il contatto.
c'è la percezione di essere piacevole, non piacevole, neutro c'è il desiderio per ciò che è piacevole o lo spingere via di ciò che non è piacevole c'è l'identità con quel desiderio
c'è l'identificazione con quel desiderio e c'è il potenziamento e così continuiamo a diventare e diventare e diventare e così continuiamo a diventare e diventare e diventare
the likeable cake in inglese io in inglese it's a transitive verb io amo mettiamo io amo il cibo gradevole likeable cake scusate torta torta gli agi di calore gli agi di calore psicologicamente it's cake likeable want I
Quindi dal punto di vista psicologico, invece, è la torta gradevole voglio io.
Questo è l'ordine in cui sorgono.
Mangio.
E poi mangio.
Questo è il piccolo salto nel fare.
Quindi ora iniziamo a capire come creiamo questa condizione dentro noi stessi.
Quindi adesso cominciamo a capire com'è che creiamo questo condizionamento dentro di noi.
Quindi vedete quanto è importante cogliere queste intenzioni.
Perché tutto il nostro condizionamento dipende da questa intenzione.
Perché tutto il nostro condizionamento dipende da quella intenzione.
Quindi quando riusciamo a percepire chiaramente quell'intenzione, è proprio qui che abbiamo il potere di cambiare il nostro condizionamento.
Se vedo un desiderio che è inesistente, allora non devo impararlo.
Se io vedo un desiderio che non è salutare, allora non necessariamente devo dargli energia.
E in questo modo quel vecchio condizionamento poco a poco morirà.
Naturalmente questo sembra molto facile, ma tutti sapete dalla vostra meditazione che non è così facile.
La difficoltà sta proprio nel stare fermi insieme a quella desiderio, a quella voglia.
Questi condizionamenti, questi condizionamenti insoliti, possono solo essere esauriti all'interno della conoscenza.
Questi condizionamenti non salutari possono solo esaurirsi all'interno della coscienza.
quindi ho già usato questa metafora del computer questi condizionamenti rimangono dentro di noi come delle potenzialità è solo quando si preme il bottone o c'è una chiave allora questo condizionamento sorge il Buddha aveva la parola Anusaya per questo
Buddha usava la parola anusaya quindi le tendenze latenti quindi noi non sappiamo affatto qual è il nostro condizionamento affinché non sorgono le condizioni affinché noi premiamo quel bottone allora
Qui vediamo, in questa piccola sezione della catena dell'Originazione Dipendente, la relazione tra sensazione e tanha, e desiderio.
E lo vediamo, è proprio lì che si creano i problemi.
Se noi vediamo questo errato desiderio,
questo è il rato desiderio e l'intenzione è quella l'intenzione
Quindi se noi riusciamo a vedere questo desiderio che nasce e riusciamo a vedere l'intenzione legata al desiderio, riusciamo a starci insieme e non dargli energia, allora, questo desiderio è come fosse un animale, non dargli energia, allora vedremo che lentamente se ne va.
Sì, quindi puoi capire, per esempio, come nella chiesa cristiana antica i mistici si guardavano questi desideri come devoli.
Quindi potete capire come i mistici del cristianesimo vedevano questi desideri come il diavolo.
E loro per fare questo dovevano vederli come una cosa separata da sé, come un potere condizionato che non era loro, che non era loro stessi.
Poi, ovviamente, le persone cominciarono a credere che esistessero.
più tardi poi le persone hanno cominciato a credere che effettivamente esistevano che non vuol dire che non ci siano degli esseri malvagi ma la confusione con loro con i nostri devoli inneri è un grande errore
Ma è un grosso errore confondere questi con i nostri diavoli interni.
Quindi con questo divenire noi dobbiamo poi completare il ciclo.
Quindi una volta che cominciamo questo atto allora attraverserà un processo e arriverà alla fine.
o dalla posizione delle tre vite quindi al termine della nostra vita noi avremo creato tutte quelle condizioni che in qualche modo ci spingeranno in una nuova vita una nuova esistenza
Ora, vi ricordo che per rinunciare a questo processo, iniziamo di nuovo con questa ignoranza.
Allora voglio ricordarvi che per disfare tutto questo processo noi dobbiamo ricominciare dall'ignoranza.
È un po' come il castello di carte, se tu togli la carta che sta alla base tutto il castello casca.
Ricordatevi che questo non conoscere, questa ignoranza, è il non conoscere le tre caratteristiche.
Quindi ogni volta che noi vediamo una di queste caratteristiche è come togliere una carta da questo intero edificio del me.
Quindi quando vediamo questa reazione tra la sensazione vedana e il desiderio stiamo capendo questa caratteristica del sofferenza.
Quindi noi stiamo comprendendo questa caratteristica della sofferenza.
Quindi stiamo radicando l'ignoranza e un'altra piccola carta viene sfilata.
Ed è così nel suo complesso che funziona questa ruota dell'originazione dipendente.
Ora, c'è qualcosa di altro, voglio dire, che connetta questa origenazione dipendente con la virtù.
Quando senti, soprattutto nel buddismo del Theravada, la lezione della origenazione dipendente, tende a essere un po' pesante.
quando sentite questi insegnamenti dell'originazione dipendente nella tradizione Theravada tendono a essere tutti un po' cerebrali e ci dimentichiamo che in realtà include e comprende anche la vita del cuore quindi quando diciamo avijja non conoscendo
Quando diciamo vigia, non conoscere, questo riguarda la comprensione.
Dal punto di vista del cuore è una posizione di innocenza.
Iniziamo con questo non conoscere, poi, infortunatamente, facciamo un errore.
Quindi partendo da questa non conoscenza noi sfortunatamente purtroppo facciamo un errore.
Quindi non ci si deve sentire in colpa per questo errore.
È solo un errore.
So that underneath our mistake, which of course causes me a lot of suffering, there is this platform of not meaning to do harm.
quindi al di sotto di questo errore per il quale non si è responsabile in qualche modo c'è comunque questa idea del non volere fare del male quindi non conoscere e non voler fare del male vanno insieme quindi poi passiamo through this process of conditioning which causes me suffering and helps other people to suffer too
quindi entriamo in questo processo in cui noi creiamo sofferenza a noi stessi ed è una specie di aiuto di stimolo alla sofferenza degli altri provoca la sofferenza degli altri ricordate che nessuno può causare a voi sofferenza psicologica
ricordate che non c'è nessuno che può causare a voi la sofferenza psicologica è tutta autoprodotta quindi anche se potete essere feriti fisicamente la nostra sofferenza interna è autocreata
ed è dovuta alla reazione a ciò che gli altri fanno o dicono è per questo che il Buddha dice il mondo che vuole litigare con me non sono io che litigo col mondo lui è in pace con il mondo quindi ora attraverso questo processo di meditazione e vivere virtuoso noi iniziamo a cambiare questo intero condizionamento
Quindi attraverso questo processo della meditazione, della vita virtuosa, noi cominciamo a cambiare tutto questo condizionamento interno.
E insieme arriva anche una crescita di saggezza.
Quindi, nella nostra vita virtuosa e nella nostra pratica della meditazione, tutto questo ci porta verso la retta visione o la retta opinione, il modo di vedere le cose.
Quindi questa disciplina cambia anche tutto quello che c'è nel nostro cuore dagli stati negativi e non salutari in quelli positivi e salutari.
Per esempio l'odio si trasforma in amore.
e alla fine il processo finale suppone anche una purificazione quindi c'è l'illuminazione e la purificazione questa purificazione è completa intera
significa che questa innocenza adesso sorge come purezza quindi quello che era l'innocenza
non conoscenza diventa saggezza immacolata
Quindi questo è il processo attraverso il quale tutte le nostre sofferenze e tutti i nostri discomforti vengono a finire.
E è per questo motivo che nella comprensione buddista il stato del cielo, che è il stato bello, o del cielo, non può mai essere permanente.
Ed è per questo che, secondo la concezione buddhista, lo stato del paradiso o dell'inferno non possono mai essere permanenti.
Perché queste sono cose create.
Quindi quando noi parliamo del nibbana, noi parliamo di altro.
Qualcosa che va oltre questa ruota dell'originazione dipendente.
Per questo noi tutte le mattine diciamo a coloro che sono consapevoli sono nelle vicinanze di o alla presenza del Nibbana.
Quindi quando noi pratichiamo la meditazione stiamo osservando questa ruota dell'originazione dipendente.
Quindi abbiamo già trasceso quel processo.
Purtroppo non riusciamo a mantenere quella posizione.
Perché?
Perché questa catena, questa ruota continua a risucchiarci nel samsara.
Quindi la nostra pratica è diventare più forti e più stabili in questa consapevolezza.
Questa posizione di pura consapevolezza.
Ed è questo il processo del risveglio, risvegliarci da questo sogno.
Ecco.
Quindi...
Bene, quindi puoi chiamare la bellina magari alle 5-8.
Oh, scusami, continuo a dimenticare, sì.
5-8 Piero, qualcosa così.
E poi ci sarà la campana.
Sì, e nella prossima mezz'ora o so, prendi tempo solo per sentire rilassato.
Se vuoi continuare la meditazione di cammino come meditazione di insight, per favore faccia così.
Quindi la prossima mezz'ora fate una camminata rilassata, però se volete fare la camminata come meditazione dell'insight, mettetevi liberi di farlo.
Ma se volete solo fare una camminata tranquilla e rilassata per rilassare la mente, portare quella mente rilassata poi nella vostra meditazione seduta, fatelo.
Se ci sono domande che sorgono, le domande sul Dhamma mettetele qui nel cestino.
Piuttosto che pensarci, abbiate pazienza, tutto vi sarà rivelato domenica.
fermiamo per un momento e lasciamo che sorga qualsiasi pensiero che deve sorgere.
Spero che le mie parole siano state di una qualche utilità per voi e sinceramente mi auguro che voi siate liberati prima piuttosto che poi.
Grazie.
Quindi forse ringrazio la bella a 8 o'clock di nuovo.